like this when we meet
without
even
thinking about it
i've i will stimulate his muscles
without him even knowing that i'm doing
this but the clash come together for
nikki
means that
his muscles will be stimulated
so i've actually added to my problem
i've actually given him a better
something to fight back with oh that
that thing up
so
i call this the splash
what you do is you come in and you take
your hand off
but you you hold that leg
you won't see this
when you do if you are
you don't see it
but you have to feel the role
so you feel that
and just like the sankyo
is the ikea
all right so you need to
so that you can get that
if you
push it to get if you push it to get to
there
this is too thin
he now can be strong and you don't get
past the next bit we've all been there
we
if you do what i call the splash
now you can go see my hand and his hand
they're going this way they're not going
into his head so i can
and he'll come down
now what my partner should be feeling is
okay
you know he should be thinking oh this
is the same
the same direction that i
felt with the other techniques if he
can't feel that with the saint kyo the
kaiser nagi the ikkya if he doesn't feel
that then obviously you're making each
technique individual
and aikido cannot be
there's no start there's a start there's
no end they say there's no end in aikido
so
thank you
i'm expecting john to
feel the same or different
so that's different
and i'm expecting john
to feel
the same
and then
we know that part so i call it the
splash you hit it you back off
you hit it you back off and make a shape
that should end up here
the same strength same strength
if he's up here then of course you
haven't won anyhow so you're wasting
your time whatever you do
he's got to be
below your navel
so look i've had the same hang ups and
problems that you've had i've gone
i get this bit scentsy but now i feel
like i'm only i'm over stretching
and i had a teacher said well why don't
you move up then
oh am i allowed to
if i asked you in your daily life i said
oh can you take me at heathrow but can
you take me via leeds airport you go you
crazy
you're paying i'll take you there so so
we're
we're actually not trusting
the one good thing we've got
when he's still there and i've got to do
that and i'll fill this block
then i didn't get it right so i have to
unpick it unwind it
thanks i'll use you again gentlemen when
it's light
and you reduce the strength you reduce
the brick wall then you know you're
advancing
so please don't just say
well i can't get it i can't get it
that's not really an answer you can't
get it
when he falls forward like that
like that you know you've got the same
chao you know you've got the kaiser nagi
you've got them all because he's he's
being spun away from you like a
gyroscope
doing this light stuff because he was
always about
you know
firm grip
look you know he needed he knew he
pushed me off balance there naturally
because he wondered what hit him
and his muscles reacted without him
knowing and i went off balance if i go
here
and he's sort of left going outwards
then
it's the right way so we're going to do
now if you don't see the splashing over
but what you do is
i turn until that becomes natural
i don't turn my hand or else it means
that uh my elbow's too high
all okay as long as that feels their
height